okay PayPal and now it's not showing up
yet but I like that I'd like to say
hello you know I like the chat chat love
but for the rest show you know um
anyways we're playing what is this
called called romance - never again
let me just skip this nonsense I need to
say that yeah yeah it's peripera there's
we all know this I don't know a single
thing about this whole game I don't know
what's thing like I barely even know the
title Borderlands 2 okay get to welcome
her and I work at that forever I guess
telltale no I think it's a first-person
shooter not entirely sure I'm also I
know torch I mean is that bad I don't
know okay I can't let's do this your
game and that's making hot friends
let me just say camp let me just make
sure to her class all right no can I
make it seven no one died no it's
multiplayer that's gaming yes sir I
don't think it's like nobody can freakin
just join my game cuz I don't want
people which is just joining my game all
right yeah no no I don't want a ssin
it gives gone okay honey out suppose on
music a little aware I can't it
perfectly so this is behind the scenes
of how I like it you know Betty askin ok
play allow that time talking about okay
let's do this place games or fantasies
where the world's called Pandora just a
container tentacles and disappoint then
they vanished into the wastelands
certain that the vault held no treasure
at all they were wrong it's my voice and
bring order to the savage planet and
through their excavations Hyperion
uncovered evidence of an even greater
vault their leader vowed to find it to
use its power to civilize the
borderlands once and for all time but I
period were the only ones searching for
the next vaults alien power the call of
danger and load is not so easily
resisted certain warriors came to
Pandora in droves to uncovered
some would call them adventurous others
call them fools okay it's fine I guess
he named when everyone's at me yeah this
gas thing he said like a chicken hurt
now four-legged he thirsted so huh
he is a [ __ ] or some oats come on some
of that
huh
what huh
yeah he's down far
[Music]
it's a business the endless rain
oh dang Megan Amina it was reppin it cuz
it's just the Sun Wow
[Music]
I think it man
I guess you just
hmm
Zehra as a number huh
does that handsome jack is he dead or is
using a robot wait mathis characters I
hate the back one Sassin necromancer
psycho that existed they were talking
with this guy
gods are king
did I look on sarkar head I think it's
break involved um skin whoa okay feeling
blue I guess you don't actually do
anything except change the color
great another hunter digging that grave
look okay okay
Aradia Quellin one golden key I'm free
right there partner
and you can't tell
[Music]
I'm coming come on no faster bro
whoa do you know this an option thank
you
[Music]
just a little security gotta keep those
bully moms at Bay or the rip your I know
that poem on like the look game already
in this game well well this place is
beautiful
I think the chair hello that's our you'd
better I guess dress in your eyes I
guess that's right don't kill him he's
awesome
yeah you only get this gun huh John I
get my first gun ok guess this is a bit
the first mission Hey I don't know how
it is
sure okay so how do I do this mission is
there like a legend past true oh but
it's just kicking got there
okay Hannah's rank
here you
okay so I gotta get eyeball okay let me
see where's frickin ID laws
okay where do I was freaking with
trophies i from it looks like it was
like on top of the building
alright wait what the hell I'm gonna
have to have company for this you know
see here he went through there I go
through there
oh there's an objective says the
objective is
what do you do with the I eat the rotor
easily
yeah here we go
clap job that's a higher name okay I
guess we're going for it sorry sir I
can't where is this for trap I mean it
that way
I get where is it okay let's do this
is there another one
because that's true so I can just walk
over this yes I can
that's dope okay hello robot where you
go
well that's quite a better than I say oh
it's a big one
Thank You Man hey where Oh
robot where do you go there you go bang
knuckle dragger well we're gonna destroy
this fall it's kind of got like no no
check yeah he's kept like there's my
ready go where do you go
I got him
whoa bro
yeah chairman squad taking on money okay
I can't get good good
hey you know what very true you know I I
come it man this guy's always right
listen to any help okay yeah whoa thank
you sir
great
well it was nice knowing you
I hear getting eaten alive by bullybots
isn't such a bad way to go let me get
that for you
executing phase shift
whoa getting crushed I'm chase be enough
of them
why can't I take this can't can how I
feel ready yeah it says to some of this
pathways know that's maybe they were
just a little bout that you know just
try to keep it tight you know
you can't get get get that way where is
this way where are you
wait Sam I done okay her ward and we
gonna pay my weight in it that chip -
tick cleaning up the back yeah do this
next time thanks for watching you thank
ya